on the wall last time you looked in the  mirror what did the mayor say to you oh  like a crazy person did you just hear  yourself say you know the mary did not  talk haven't to tell you the question at  the time it really did I had a lot of  fun sitting with the entire cast of the  Huntsman's winters war Charlize Theron  and Emily Blunt work comedy really and  with a baby on the way Emily is ready to  get all these media obligations over  with I'm sitting down so that's always  better than standing you make it look so  good now of course  Emily is expecting baby number two with  husband John Krasinski but how is their  two year old hazel handling the new  arrival perplex  she doesn't stall it hasn't you supposed  to understand that there's a baby in  there so it makes no sense to her I'm  sure if it would make sense the grumpy  little here's the deal it makes no sense  to me  alright that's problematic